But what happens when a person takes a drug? That is, why do some people take
drugs again and again and sometimes to access? We do know that genetics can
play a role in how reinforcing a drug's effect is for an individual. Now, a
drug reinforcer Is any drug that produces effects that cause or result in the
person taking the drug again. Drugs of abuse are termed positive reinforcers.
We'll discuss reinforcers in more detail in our lesson on learning, which is
the next lesson. One factor that plays a major role in the reinforcing
effectiveness of a drugs action Is the root of administration that the drug is
delivered. The faster the onset of a drug's action, the greater reinforcing
effects. So injecting and inhaling routes are more reinforcing. In the oral
route, because the drug enters the central nervous system faster during
injecting and inhaling. Now, for the oral route, the drug has a path through
the digestive system and compete for metabolism for whatever else is in the
stomach. For example, pizza or cheeseburger. Thus the drug takes longer to
reach the sites of action in the central nervous system when taken orally.
Here, let's look at these a little closer. Injecting drugs is one of the
fastest and most dangerous routes of administration for a variety of reasons.
Including the increased risk of blood-borne diseases such as HIV and AIDS,
hepatitis In collapsing of veins after long time injecting. Inhalation or
smoking over an extended period of time can result in damage to the lungs and
bronchi, and sometimes results in coughing fits and increased mucus production.
Other roots of administration include snorting, or even transdermal patches.
You're most likely aware of nicotine patches that are used as a method for
quitting smoking. Patches allow for extended release of the drug. There are
even patches for powerful pain reducing drugs that are used for the treatment
of some cancers. But now, let's switch gears, and talk a little bit about the
brain.